job creation slowed to 236 000 for the
month almost reaching the level that
President Biden said would stabilize the
economy and prices more Americans joined
the labor force and wage gains fell
slightly which could help to further
cool inflation
the lower wage gains is yet another
necessary evil to calming down the rate
of inflation it's one of these
unfortunate Necessities that is seen by
an economist says you know what you have
to do to bring about a lower inflation
rate the unemployment rate currently
sits at 3.5 percent which is lower than
what we saw under Trump lower than what
we saw under President Obama lower than
we saw under President Bush and given
how Trump would endlessly brag about uh
the economy he would love to have seen
these numbers during his tenure Biden
should be doing the exact same thing
because 3.5 percent is essentially what
we would call full employment